the first eight and half minutes of this
movie are a rehash of the first one
complete with epic credits got this guy
on loan from the Empire Strikes Back set
now even these guys should have known
they weren't really in a Fortress of
Solitude
the background is clearly blue screen
criminals on Krypton are held by two
hula hoops you know for kids okay okay
the return to the first movie forgets
that Marlon Brando existed probably
because he would have been too expensive
to remember jor-el jor-el is not here
man and you didn't say that in the
Frisby prison last time you said it
before you were thrown into the Frisby
prison
can we see Superman's mother carrying
him in a colorful blanket through a Star
Wars set why is this one lone green
crystal part of the plan isn't green the
color of Krypton aisle who can cares
just get to the action already exactly
how much of the first movie does this
second movie think I need a refresher
course on I wonder if this is the
Superman where Clark Kent kisses Lex
Luthor on the mouth and tells him I knew
it was you Superman
to implies that Superman saved Lois in a
very traditional way and expertly
forgets that he flew around the goddamn
world a hundred times to reverse time
the Golden Gate Bridge is in some sort
of danger cliche in a flashback hey they
misspelled honor on this credit that is
hilarious
Cup wait a minute doing some research
doing some research only they got a guy
who did a hard day's night to do this
movie I guess one hundred percent of the
world's faction directors were Indiana
jonesing a Star Wars and a James Bond
somewhere but Kent steals the Sean
Connery from the Bond movies get your
head out of the clouds Kent where you
been for the past 12 hours watching the
opening credits of Superman to I think
also how in the world does Clark not
know anything about a terrorist attack
at the Eiffel Tower after 12 hours
everyone knows Superman exists at this
point right Tower in Paris he knows
where the Eiffel Tower is Olsen Perry
White would be excellent at cinema since
Bill Cosby photo in 1981 proves you
shouldn't put pictures of anybody famous
anywhere in your movie because one day
they'll be wrapped up in a scandal yes
stashed and stairs cop seriously becomes
preoccupied with English to French
translation and that's how Lois Lane
gets past him despite all of this Lois
somehow misses all the time-traveling
equipment stored in the Apple Tower from
Tomorrowland
I hope
not many sins left to be forgiven by the
end of this movie more than a hundred
for sure she use something sounded like
someone moving underneath except she did
not make any major movements or noises
this is some scripted bullshit
how is Superman not there yet the guy
went around the world several times in
seconds the guy made the Kessel run in
less than 12 parsecs
he's flying but his cape doesn't know it
started hey kids that's richard
griffiths aka Vernon Dursley playing
terrorist number 3 in Superman 2 now
leaving Harry Potter in his hands every
summer is an even worse idea than it was
before Superman gets here at the exact
time of the stuff happening how is Lois
able to jump straight down from her
position under the elevator yet still
land on solid ground
this means the elevator was mere feet
from crashing into a solid platform
right remember Superman stopped this
thing where you can see a full view of
all of Paris from the height they were
at take that space sudden Zod space
breath strip is sudden the power of an
h-bomb in space is apparently enough to
freeze odd and his cronies from the
smell the globe album cover prison also
the Phantom Zone is awfully close to
Earth and convenient for plotting
sequels Clark Kent is a super dick I
mean seriously he walks away from this
kind of crash without anyone calling the
National Enquirer movie that is not
about Lex Luthor sure finds a way to
cram Lex Luthor into the story for no
reason what purpose does it serve Zod to
attack three people wandering around the
moon can they not see planet Earth
nearby the closer we come to an up the
spear with only one son the more our
molecular density gives us unlimited
powers he figured that out in a goddamn
hurry almost as though he's friends with
a screenwriter movie denies us the scene
of all the NASA people freaking the fuck
out that they can't contact our
astronauts anymore I told you this this
hologram is way better than any hologram
technology that's come before or since
but one question though why did they
even bother doing this if they had a way
out of the prison why not wait until
after lights-out because now a guard
knows they're missing and they haven't
even escaped yet he's freeze just what
does a spotlight operator doing right
now that he doesn't see them
oh he's watching a big game oh well then
forgive my interrogation apologies
fellow sports fan you go on with your
bad self
watching games while actively moving the
spotlight none of the guards saw this
hot-air balloon flying over the prison
only now after several minutes of the
prison guard seeing the hologram does
the alarm go off very good miss
Tessmacher very good movie continues to
show of previous movies villain in my
face despite the fact that goddamn
Terence Stamp is in this movie already
doing a finest job of villainy No due
north um aren't you both gonna freeze
your balls off going to the North Pole
and the clothes you're wearing
aren't you already why didn't you drop
by a Burlington Coat Factory before
making this trip ah 1980 when a
newspaper writer is taking pictures on
the job with a Polaroid instant camera I
get the sense this happens way more
often than we think but still lucky
Superman's here today by the way some
assholes falling off the Empire State
Building right now but that ended
tragically Superman catches the boy who
already fell for 20 seconds and
definitely should be dead
he hadn't been a ghost Falls Clark is
not around as usual
Lois takes two movies to figure out the
most obvious fact in all of comic book
obviousness good thing the swath of
Niagara Falls tourists who were around
this hotdog stand cleared out so that
Superman could turned back into Clark
Kent unseen also since no one is here
working at this hot dog stand and since
no money is exchanged it is an
undeniable fact that Superman just stole
two hot dogs I just now figured out who
paid for this movies budget
it was fresca look it's his home it's
Superman's home Lex finds the fortress
of solitude by snowmobiling around the
Arctic for a bit and he's got a fancy
new radar sure but Superman isn't
currently flying here so that thing was
worthless right why didn't you go before
we left that was two days ago
God Dan this woman held her pee and poop
for 48 hours that's amazing
what did Luthor do with his waist no
possibility for parole your father
jor-el thought long and hard on that
question wait a minute Lex has been
talking to this thing several times with
no response
suddenly he asks a question and it
responds how does it not know that this
isn't kal-el your father jor-el thought
long and hard on that question so just
in case some French terrorists happen to
have a bomb waiting to explode on the
Apple Tower don't throw it into space
that explains the three alpha waves I've
been getting on my pot box my question
is why is it the story of the astronauts
who were killed on the moon all over the
news right now I gotta admit you know
your disguise is nearly perfect you had
me fooled
Oh is he ever gonna be sorry when she
later finds out he's Superman but he
only used human observation to try and
save her wait why does holding onto a
branch do anything when you're being
carried by rapids it's not anchored to
anything but it magically saves Lois and
she's able to swim to safety because
she's holding a branch these people
walking behind Clark
they're actively pretending they're not
wandering through a life-or-death
situation
here's your what I thought was Superman
Lois is willing to forget all the other
huge reasons why Clark is Superman
because of this one incident which they
surely wrote into this movie because
everyone got tired of hearing about how
that disguise is stupid and no one would
ever fall for yes yes but will he turn
water into wine later and now for no
reason here is an overly symbolic
rattlesnake now back to your regularly
scheduled movie I have powers beyond
reason here question might get being
faster and stronger because blah blah
Krypton blah blah earth and blahblah Sun
but laser eyes how does that derive from
your normal everyday physiology huh this
one alien is hilariously bad at Superman
powers let's all laugh at how dumb and
stupid and I laser an empty is ha ha ha
they went through all this bull to prove
Clark wasn't Superman and then in the
very next scene they're already pissing
all over it because clumsiness lava lamp
pillars area is the lovable County
Sheriff from a couple of Roger Moore
bonds the fact that this sheriff is able
to coexist in the bond and Superman
universes means there's definitely
something wrong with ours why are these
assholes just standing in the middle of
the road I'm guessing because of Larry's
high jinks but other than that junior
cop allows strange criminal chick to
massage his badge without offering up
even so much as what do you think you're
doing can you read my mind can you
picture the last movie I'm thinking of
oh forgot Lois it's cold out here
I never noticed so sorry for you dying
of hypothermia listen you warm enough he
asked several minutes after flying this
chicken to the Arctic you say this
breakfast place has blue and green
condiment containers and smaller junior
versions of both what's up with that why
is it every time there's a new alien
species or terminator that comes to a
place and time he or she doesn't belong
they always find the redneck bar it's
almost like screenwriters have a secret
wish to hurt deserving rednecks the hero
can't do it so they get the villains to
do it and it's hilarious also they
needed to go to Planet Houston because
of their misunderstanding of the
astronauts radio message but why didn't
that lead them to East Houston Idaho any
rudimentary map is gonna say go to Texas
and beyond this point there be dragons
I found this cristal it's green which
denotes kryptonite but I'm still able to
touch it in stuff because reasons what
do you think you like it I honestly
don't know anything about the fortress
of solitude what is its purpose other
than to show Superman interactive
learning videos sadly this movie has
time for the Superman flies to the
rainforest to get food that will impress
Lois scene the US Army is on the scene
and attacking and they're leading with
an unarmored Jeep and 20 foot soldiers
brilliant this Jeep wrecks by driving up
the semi that was thankfully left here
in this position for some reason also
this guy survives this probably
he's an obvious crash-test dummy kind of
fire they need machines to flow didn't
you before you got superpowers it's not
like you've been the superior race all
along you've just got these powers well
that is simply way too much fire for a
simple helicopter explosion I mean Jesus
Christ then there's a lot of fire is
there no one on this planet to even
challenge me
strangely enough yes and he will answer
to me or all of his cities will end up
like this one yeah slightly burned but
still 95% intact also shouldn't you have
dissipated I don't know a larger city
before saying this to make your threat
you know more credible and scary once
exposed to these rays all your great
powers on earth will disappear forever I
mean it's totally and completely
reversible but the plot demands that at
least sound like it's permanent you can
be hurt like an ordinary man maybe you
should consider just doing some
over-the-clothes type stuff also this
goes to show the extraordinary lengths a
man will go just to have sex with no
discussion whatsoever Superman walks
into the power draining cubicle while
Lois watches and Lois fell in love with
Superman not Natsu
losing your powers is almost like your
own personal 2001 only with weight
graphics here's another thing kal-el has
never had to worry about the little
things in life that might kill you he
has zero training and conscientiousness
this guy's gonna die the first day he
gets back to New York sex on this thing
is gonna be awful hilarious obvious
drawings on the president's faces are
hilariously obvious also these flying
bad guys and their single laser shots
completely changing the literal faces of
Mount Rushmore Jesus Christ did anyone
take this seriously kind of special
effects
how does he still maintain the right to
fuck and sleep in Superman's ice palace
after renouncing his super mandus but
there is one man here on earth who will
never kneel before you
who is the symbol sue gotta love Terence
Stamp azad here this performance is
worthy of taking us in off this vehicle
is clearly driving on the wrong side of
the road yet the movie will completely
gloss over it fine I'm just curious as
to how this car ever decided to drive on
the wrong side of the road for the shop
there are no oncoming cars no
obstructions whatsoever just an American
car driving on the British side of the
road for an entire shot for no reason
this place serves in order hot beef hot
hamburger as though you might want a
cold one hot turkey hot liver you and
Frank onions the Frank onions honest
onions blunt ones onions with
frankfurters also this diner with the
baffling menu board has two signs
letting customers know where the
bathrooms are excuse me sir would you
care to step outside
Clark has already forgotten he's not
Superman anymore but who are we kidding
this is basically if eight miles started
out at the hour and 20 minute mark
because all it does is set up the
redemption scene later during his Stein
of Superman Clark apparently never
picked up any hand-to-hand combat tips
it's funny every time I remember this
movie it starts right here where
Superman's lost his powers and it gets
beat up at a diner but there was more
than 80 minutes of setup to this a bunch
of nonsense involving Niagara Falls and
the bad guys landing in Idaho for no
real good reason this should be around
the 30 minute mark but the movie is
nearly over Jesus this guy's walking in
cold that requires lots of layering but
sure a light jacket will do and I guess
he doesn't need food or water
this motherfucker walked all the way to
the North Pole ah father
shining ice shard ex machina Oh Jean
happens in this movie I literally forgot
that dude the door is right there and
seriously this guy's based on the jaws
character in The Spy Who Loved me right
this asshole lifts Perry White's head
through a run-of-the-mill drop ceiling
tile and somehow that incapacitate Syd
as I see a headline reading Whitehouse
surrenders I wonder how to normal
everyday activities keep going on like
nothing's happened I think I might like
it but still sit well I see the green
crystal of power actually gave Superman
his powers back no explanation needed by
the way how does Superman know Zod is in
the Daily Planet building this whole
movie basically proves Superman has no
fucking clue where anything's going on
unless he's in the area but as soon as
he gets his powers back the first place
he goes is the Daily Planet I'm not sure
why that exploded but fun also this
movie is going to do not nearly as much
damage as Superman and Zod did in Man of
Steel but it's still pretty ridiculous
I didn't lead them to a desert or
mountains or something somewhere the
collateral damage would be low the big
ones just as strong as Superman you
stated a fact
i'ma shove you you gotta love these
boring fights where everyone has the
same powers the only way anyone wins is
because of the script he's caged nom how
so first off you should be able to lift
this thing because of his powers second
off Superman just put the needle back on
top of the building without securing it
so even I could knock it off I realized
odd isn't human but why does he aim is
laser sight here instead of the main
tanker behind the semi and really
absorbs the power 'fl why isn't this
little tank exploded yet wait shouldn't
the lasers at least melt the mirror this
is a little sideview mirror that's
supposed to contain this kind of heat
getting me hill board now contains
hilarious commentary on the scene here's
a fight between immortals that is so
intense the movie didn't have any money
to show it these assholes are such
workaholics they don't give a shit about
all the stuff going on outside Superman
this is the same issue Man of Steel had
in the same fight these immortals have
no real way of killing each other so
they keep inventing stupid ways to try
and do it but don't matter and have no
chance of succeeding we'll just have to
wait until someone gets their neck
broken Kentucky Fried Chicken product
placement is way too obvious but it
so continues British directors obsession
with Kentucky welcome Superman to flavor
country I think this movie paid for all
its bills in 40 seconds
I thought this thing would go the
distance if Zod ursa an on all attacked
Superman together it wouldn't know I'm
finding it extremely hard to believe
that the momentum of this boss can't be
stopped by Superman almost instantly
why would you think that is the case
he's Superman
he can take a hail of bullets you don't
think I can take a bus crash almost two
full minutes of the villains blowing New
York City sure let's double down on the
Kentucky Fried Chicken ads welcome to
flavor country when Superman took a long
time to recover from that bus accident
he totally should have been able to
shrug off sure let's double down on the
marbled ads welcome to flavor country
our victory is complete the son of
jor-el has fled bullsh-- you wanted to
kill that guy remember you wanted
revenge you didn't get it yet I'm glad
they decided to keep this piggyback ride
strictly hetero hey never heard of
parachutes no but I have her gene
Hackman and you were not Gene Hackman
what the fuck we must combine our
strength you're just now thinking of
this yeah but why why is Superman's
stronger than all three of these people
combined
since women Zod sees that all three
other Superman's were Holograms and then
stupidly thinks the fourth and final one
standing in front of him is also a
hologram
the misadventures of both the gene
Hackman continues why is superman
allowed to whisper to lex luthor for any
reason during this scene
why hasn't Zod who was a megalomaniac
ended this discussion with more commands
to kneel before him or boasts about his
penis size all of Zod and his Cruz
powers have been completely ripped out
of them but they don't feel weak or
anything like Superman felt after he did
this because surprises you're a real
pain in the neck
thank God Lois was here so that Ursa
could her female comeuppance from a girl
chick thankfully and suddenly the
fortress of solitude has a ton of
infinite caverns to throw bad guys into
yeah this kiss is gonna make her forget
about Superman but what a specific
action that is to make someone forget
about you
I guess this works if Jimmy Olsen ever
finds out the truth too right also but
the kind of magic we've seen in this
movie it's a wonder Kryptonians never
invented something so you can have sex
with a mortal woman never seen garbage
eat garbage before seriously Superman's
out to get revenge my hero this order's
to go sure he repays him for the damage
but the inconvenience alone is a dick
move Superman really needs to think
about finding more open spaces to fight
I won't let you down again I'm still
mourning those poor astronauts who died
on the moon that Superman fly up there
and bring them back for their funerals
where Richard Pryor makes his
long-awaited appearance in a Superman
film
act like you don't Bob advantage Oh
space a final frontier
begging you to shut the fuck up I got an
idea let's make the car a place of
silent reflection
let our powers combine
wait a hundred miss Brandt give this man
his money and throw in a bar of soap
your wife is still on that line flowers
how much you spend any more on this
thing you can pick the daisies off my
grave I'm Bruce Nolan for Eyewitness
News back to you first
where's my comb where's my comb cool huh
zero-point energy yeah I saved the best
inventions for myself